the Democrats mood Schiff
that's the focus of tonight's angle oh
what a difference 24 hours makes
yesterday Democrats and their media
allies were positively giddy using
phrases like blockbuster revelation
bombshell leaked an impeachment
game-changer well they were sure that a
story about John Bolton's new book would
be enough to convince for Republicans to
keep this twisted trial going but today
after the Trump defense team wrapped up
its arguments even yielding back time to
the Senate the mood on the left seems to
have well shifted or should I say it
Adams shifted I was more optimistic
yesterday morning than I am now I talked
to some of my colleagues last night a
sort of feeling that I was getting was
that they're linking arms and they're
gonna say no right now the Republicans
feel good the White House feels good the
universe of Republicans it hasn't really
expanded so you you you anticipate that
they're gonna vote against what
predictions are dangerous exciting
especially when they're about the future
but it seems unlikely hmmmm oh boy and
the faces weren't just sad over at CNN
if a picture is worth a thousand words
as they say Chuck Schumer's face red
like a Solzhenitsyn novel a lot of pain
and suffering there and on the witness's
question does he sound like a man whose
party is winning one at a time look I
hope that we have just four Republicans
all we need is four who rise to the
occasion and say we need to find out the
truth what can we react that again
please I've been looking for a new
ringtone and that's a good one but wait
what about the faces of the house
managers after the White House Counsel
finished his argument they put in all
that time and effort try to take the
president
of office with a brimming with optimism
while only in the land of fraudulent
impeachments would the lead house
manager complain that the other side
didn't spend more time arguing their
case I want to begin this afternoon with
a few observations on the rather abrupt
end to the president's case it's clear I
think today that they are still reeling
from the revelation of John Bolton's
book and what he has to say complaining
that the other side didn't use all their
time and then he grasped at another
irrelevant straw something that John
Kelly said at a speech in Florida the
president's own former chief of staff
general Kelly has stated that he
believes John Bolton the president's own
former chief of staff believes John
Bolton and and by implication does not
believe the President of the United
States okay dude the Democrats really
think this was going to work that they
were going to be able to invalidate the
last election and steal this next one by
just simply citing public statements of
former White House staffers and without
the defense team turning the tables on
the house managers themselves by these
actions you would undo the free
elections that express the will of the
American people you will damage the
faith the American people have in this
institution and in the American
democracy you will reap the bitter
harvest of the unfair partisan seeds you
sow today they must never be a narrowly
voted impeachment such an impeachment
will produce the divisive this and
bitterness in our politics for years to
come my fear is that when the Republican
wins the White House Democrats will
demand payback now even the resistance
media had to admit that using the
Democrats own words against them well it
worked I thought it was an effective set
of zingers and I bet the Republicans
really enjoyed listening to it it was it
was awkward because a lot of
what these Democrats were saying then
and he specifically included at least
two of the house managers Jerry Nadler
and Olaf green they say the opposite
today yeah that's called turning the
tables on the wolf so now the liberal
media media was basically just left
clinging to their new lifeboat and then
they merely echoed what Schiff had said
earlier about Kelly former White House
chief of staff John Kelly says that he
believes John Bolton's claimed Kelley
also said he thinks Bolton is a man of
integrity and should be heard from now
last time I checked general Kelly I like
him
he's a great guy but he's not a senator
who gets to vote on and witnesses Jake
but I think someone needs to send that
memo to Jerry Nadler as well who are the
witnesses you'll you'll see your side
will be seeking well john bolton
certainly maybe now john kelly have you
discussed the idea of calling general
kelly with with other managers or
senators no okay
so john kelly a guy who hasn't even been
at the White House for over a year now
he's going to save the Democrats
impeachment crusade well okay if that
doesn't work they always have the
Quinnipiac poll believe me that's an
intense caucus going on right now
they're all listening to each other
what's the chances they've seen the new
75 number from Quinnipiac I say pretty
damn good
to deprive witnesses is utter insanity
from a political perspective you've only
got I think 51 to 54 percent that are
behind his immediate removal from office
but 75 percent around witnesses is
political suicide they aren't telling
you is that 97 percent of the GOP is
opposed to removing Donald Trump from
office so those four moderate GOP
senators who are wringing their hands
tonight and navel-gazing the hamlet
routines well they should take note
because this is how Donald Trump was
received when a record crowd showed up
when he took the stage at a rally in New
Jersey tonight
so who exactly do these moderate
senators think they're actually
appealing to if it turns out they vote
to prolong this impeachment farce they
pin one to those people or these people
oh yes CNN MSNBC the panelists there
Chuck Todd Jake Tapper etc etc look they
don't have the votes to remove Trump
Democrats don't have those votes
everyone on television was conceding
that today so what is the point of doing
this to the country well as they did
during the Cavanaugh fight they just
want to drag this out in hopes that the
next news cycle will bring them some
some manna from heaven to damage the
president before the first ballots are
cast our reporter at the New Jersey
rally tonight tells us that they're
serving drinks called Magga Rita's and
subpoena coladas very cheeky all over
Wildwood New Jersey should these
moderate Republicans vote to help shift
Pelosi and Nadler prolong this national
nightmare there won't be enough booze
and all of New Jersey to soothe the
political pain coming their way that
will be political suicide and that's the
angle